let's try to remember what did we cover
yesterday ok I'll give you a tip let's
just start with this guy we were talking
about we were talking about right-angled
triangles right white triangles time is
ok because it's trigonometry which is
about measuring Trey ok good sorry maybe
I didn't ask it clearly before are you
ready yeah sorry I got an answer about a
third of you are we ready yeah that's
great this is not be true right and then
we are we labeled a few things for
instance we call this angle theta which
is a Greek there now by the way is a
good time even though that you should
just 22 yesterday I'm like because they
appear in this exercise you're about to
do I might just tell you a few more
Greek letters and maybe you want to
write them down as well I'm theatre was
the first one that we did the other one
was alpha okay now I actually honestly
don't know why theta tends to be the
most common one you see alpha is
actually the first letter of the Greek
alphabet I'm not joking that's where
kosher okay now alpha the next letter
it's a it's a be with a tail on it
you'll see that and that's made up oh
wait up both feet up um after that is
gamma it kind of looks like this gamma
yes yes this is exactly where a closed
on the house actually now come on how's
it pronounced
said yeah oh I can't say that I don't
know okay I'm not gonna embarrass myself
now Shh there's a few more I'm just
going to start writing them down you can
copy with them with me as we go further
they become kind of less common okay
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta is the next one I
know by the way just like in English
don't worry about Jake just like in
English letters have capitals and
lower-case these ones all lowercase
Delta the capital Delta you've actually
been using for a long time just not in
maths you've been using it in science so
that's the capital for Delta and it
usually means if you if you write
chemical equations like in a a CL plus
hate lovable anyway I mean change it
still means the same thing in a mass as
well epsilon is next kappa epsilon looks
like this and you can epsilon which like
that back nice i tell my so it's a
backwards number three then I goes your
first five letters and then the next one
yeah thank you for that the next they're
all kind of randomly assorted from there
so for instance another one that you've
been writing for a while is this guy I
there's also if you write play but
instead of writing two lines down there
if you just do one vicar be one like
that that's tell also just pee on that
no ideas
happy here with me ah if you're a circle
and you chuck a line through it like
that oh that's fine um there's another
one I think these ones all here or a
lowercase and these ones are capitals
but there's one I actually turned her
what the lower case is I only know what
the capital is and that Sigma yeah so
you look on it's ok Sigma yeah kind of
um so that's that Sigma so it's using a
lot of places because it's the Greek
letter that corresponds to an S it often
is used in Matt to indicate a sub as for
some when you're adding up a whole bunch
of things on there's a whole topic in
here who is it your letter is neato I'm
called Sigma notation but that's for
later okay yep using differentiation
kind of not really it's not the main
placement yeah look tau tau another
another important one which doesn't come
so much in math is a bigger um you'll
just you'll just use them and you'll
write them over and over again and it's
pretty much it no I think that's very
nice article that's a pretty reasonable
is dead
ah it's not so much that it's science of
us combined it's that scientists and
mathematicians they all turn to the
Greeks because the Greeks did he just
stands and that so that's right so they
go you'll see a whole bunch of these now
you know what David